hello everybody my name is Nyan I'm the
black female engineer and today we are
going apartment hunting in New York I am
so excited this is something I have been
trying to do and by this I mean renting
in New York I've been trying for the
last like six months I came down here
back in August and did some apartment
hunting and oh my goodness it's it was
quite awful but yes we're apartment
hunting so here are the details for the
Tesla Apartments I'm looking for
along with the price ranges so I'm going
to bring out my computer so I can make
sure I have everything organized but
here they are okay my price range is
three thousand to five thousand dollars
for an apartment keep in mind these
expenses are going to be shared and so
per person I'm looking at 1500 to 2500
per person but yes in terms of the
overall apartment three thousand to five
thousand dollars for at least a one
bedroom but I really want a two bedroom
so here are the things that are my needs
I'm pretty simple really under the needs
category it comes down to having at
least one full bedroom having laundry in
building at the very least and updated
finishes then in terms of wants I really
want two or more bedrooms and laundry
inside the unit itself and to be even
more particular like not those European
style like one machine laundry like I
want a separate washer dryer two
different units in the apartment that
would really be fantastic for me really
really my focus is Brooklyn I used for
this entire hunt streeteasy.com it was
actually a pretty simple process just
sending a quick message whenever I
wanted to tour a place and by that night
or the next morning I'd hear back and so
it was pretty simple and I very much
recommended for New York City at least
so without further Ado let's check out
the very first apartment
[Music]
amen
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and this was for 850 square feet it was
in Brooklyn specifically in Bushwick and
I really liked it it had really great
amenities the building did it had a gym
pretty like small boutique gym with like
maybe like four machines and some free
weights but honestly that's all I need
it had a gym and also a rooftop deck and
so when it's warm I'm sure I would enjoy
having that you know available and so
really there aren't many qualms about
this unit also had the washer dryer in
unit the separate washer dryer and I was
really shocked to see that it had two
full bathrooms not one and a half
bathrooms but two full ones on top of
there being two full bedrooms and so
overall I really did like this unit now
something that I did not like and really
like only real big thing that I didn't
like was that
because of where it is so it's in
Bushwick
traveling in other places in Brooklyn
and specifically to Manhattan would be a
bit more strenuous than I would like it
to be it would take probably 30 40 50
minutes going to certain areas and I
don't really like that I don't know
New York too too well I haven't I can't
say that I've explored too much of it
and so I want a place that I can easily
hop around and it won't be too arduous
especially with these cold months coming
in so that's one thing to note but yeah
overall I really did like this unit so
overall that is that unit let's check
out the next
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so this unit
where did we get okay let's start with
just like things I didn't like which are
many let's start with just things I
didn't like one the bathroom if you saw
is in the kitchen
which is disgusting just
[Music]
that alone like get me get me out of
here
um the bathroom was in the kitchen it
was one it was only one bathroom and
only like one bedroom
now get this on Street Easy the listing
was for said two bedrooms the reason it
qualified as two bedrooms is because in
the living room the place where I had
the fireplace there and I'll try to add
the specific clip here there's a small
divot in the ceiling that
I guess according to New York law that
divot
makes it qualify as two bedrooms
there's no door there's no separate like
divide there's no wind like just that
small little thing made it
qualify as two bedrooms that's absurd
because yeah get understand my
disappointment when I showed up to that
unit that showing and I'm expecting two
bedrooms and one bathroom and the
bathroom is in the kitchen and it's only
one bedroom and because of the way it's
tiled so there are separate entrances to
the unit there's an entrance to go into
the living room and there's an entrance
to go into the kitchen there's no
entrance for like that middle room what
ideally probably would be someone's
bedroom if I have guests over and they
need to go to the bathroom or go to the
kitchen because they're in the same
place
um they would need to go through that
big that my bedroom they'd have to get
through my bedroom to go to the kitchen
or the bathroom
and vice versa or go outside into the
Hall to do to get to the different
places logistically that just sounds
like an absolute Nightmare and just
absolute awful like I don't want any
part in it at all like I'm okay this
unit was four thousand dollars for 700
square feet as well so in terms of like
the money uh like what you're getting
for your money it really to me wasn't
much uh but I did like the neighborhood
the neighborhood it was Williamsburg and
so that's pretty close to Manhattan and
just other places in Brooklyn making it
super efficient to hop around uh pretty
just pretty easily if that is something
I liked about the unit but other than
that yo I I didn't like it at all at all
let me see was there anything else
yeah yep that that's about it that was
that unit so let's check out the next
y'all
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this next unit was forty two hundred
dollars but because it had two months
free it actually ended up being about
thirty five hundred dollars for a 12
month lease which is actually really
good especially because of the space
this unit had that honestly is the
biggest thing going for this
apartment it was watch let me check it
was 1 000 square feet had an upstairs
and a downstairs and it was in the
neighborhood that I actually really love
it was also in Williamsburg so just like
I was talking before I could easily hop
around whenever I so pleased now that
being said yes I love this face so so
much a thousand square feet is really
great especially for that price
but because it was just one large
basement area and not divvied up in any
way so the primary bedroom is in the
basement and then any office area that I
need would need to be in the basement as
well I work from home if that means I'm
spending a majority of my day
underground basically which I do not
appreciate that much so I had a lot of
space and was in the location that I
really loved and it did have a washer
dryer but as for amenities that was
pretty much it
overall it was pretty it was an okay
unit it was good
love the space don't really love that
part of me spending most of my time in
the basement unless I need food and
that's when I would go up to the kitchen
and Scurry back down
to the basement again and so yeah that's
really my biggest qualm about this unit
and so let's check out the last unit
foreign
[Music]
have you ever seen like an apartment or
a pair of shoes or honestly anything
that you see nothing really wrong with
it but you just don't like it like
at all that was me with this unit for
some reason which is really weird
because it was super modern I had really
nice finishes the person who toured the
place said that we would be the first
people in that unit because there's a
whole new building and all that and so
it was really nice looking and really
just
yeah just cool in that way but for some
reason I just did not like it it had
three bedrooms and two bathrooms which
it's the yeah which means it's the
apartment in this list with the most
amount of bedrooms and that would
provide a lot of flexibility in terms of
just organizing this place because it
would allows for the ability to have the
full primary bedroom while also having
either two full office spaces or a guest
bedroom and an office on top of that and
so I really did enjoy that flexibility
and
yeah I know like you you all I think
need to tell me what you think about
this unit because I do like that
industrial look of it it had the washer
and dryer that I needed two full
bathrooms along with the three full
bedrooms and it was very modern and
clean but yeah those are the four units
for this video I did about 10 at least
10 tours which I do plan to create like
a whole series of the different
apartments I toured but yeah let me know
in the comments which ones you guys are
leaning towards which ones are absolute
nose and which ones you think based off
of my commentary I need to take a second
look at because maybe I'm not seeing
something that should actually be at the
top or near the top of my list so let me
know what you guys think and yeah I'm
gonna see y'all very soon so thank you
so much have a great rest of your day
bye